hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine lieben
freunde zu einem neuen video hier sind
es bereits sind hinter eingeblendet und
zwar rate ich heute mal wieder euer
alter hier gute befindet sich hinter der
kamera erstmal juli
wie geht s maul ihr konntet einige
bilder von euch mir auf twitter wenden
und jude hat da einige rausgesucht und
ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt an mit
dem ersten foto wer den anfang habe ich
dir was einfach das ist das erste bild
ich sehe nicht ihr gesicht ja keine
ahnung was soll ich jetzt sagen also sie
hat auf jeden fall nur die halle aus der
vizeminister von de das bringt mich aber
gerade 0,0 weiter aber auch mit seinem
bezahlt sondern ich will sagen 14 13 13
verdammt okay noch keinen punkt dann
habe ich hier ein foto von einem mädchen
auf einem autorisiert das alter von dem
auto geschrieben und das alter von sich
ich glaube ich werde er das auto alter
erraten als ihr alter sie sitzt auf
einem ganz ganz alten deutsch
deswegen würde ich sagen ich hab das ist
mehr instyle jetzt eine college jacke
und an die karre an sich auch also ich
würde sie auf 14 auch wieder schätzen
und das auto auf 70 das halt ganz schwer
sie ist 16
der deutsche ist 39 70 jahre höher
bisschen hat all das dritte bild dass
sie das in einen ganz lieben mädchen
dann gucken was du sagst
da bin ich einfach unfassbar schlecht
darin ja ich würde wieder sagen 14 15 15
bisher habe ich immer noch null punkte
jetzt habe ich ein bild von einem jungen
für licht der zwar filter im gesicht
aber vielleicht schafft es ja trotzdem
durch den alten hunde ja dann gehen
12 bilder mit gütern das ist auch wieder
ein junger mal gucken ob du den raten
kann ich weiß halt auch bartwuchs
zumindest mehr als ich 18 19
wann immer ein jahr aber mit filter ist
es ja eben geschafft deswegen hier noch
ein bild mit filter da ist halt die
sache dass dieser filter glaube ich
insgesamt die haut auch ein bisschen
jünger erscheinen
das ist auch schwer 15 12 12 das hier
ist die nächste person
das hat auch wieder die hälfte vom
besichtigen von einem handy verdeckt sie
ist auf jeden fall ein großer paris
fällen und sie hatte auf jeden fall auch
schminkt produkte liegen und halt so ein
schminkspiegel den sarah auch hat das
heißt wenn sie sich schneller von
medizinischen mit 12 ich will sagen 17
ist richtig danke auf dem welt kann man
das mädchen zumindest gut erkennen
ich habe da noch gar keine ahnung wie
das ist so schwierig 13 19 19 was kannst
du eigentlich auch wieder ein ganz
liebes mädchen ohne filter sind bild
vielleicht schaff ich weiß halt auch nie
was ich dann irgendwie sagen soll also
ihr seht ihr die fotos nehmen hier
eingeblendet ich kann es einfach 0,0
einschätzen da gucke ich halt auch immer
so haye ist sie geschminkt was hat sie
so an schmuck vielleicht et cetera pp
und hier würde ich sagen 18
aber ich will es tatsächlich erst 14 14
sagt es auf jeden fall nicht als kellner
arbeiten halter hier habe ich mal wieder
einen jungen für dich vielleicht kannst
du es da besser ich würde sagen 12
ehrlich
also habe ich bisher nur jungs erwarten
das bild das wieder mit filter ich
glaube aber die brille ist echt ok also
es ist halt im auto und ich glaube es
ist auch vorne weil hinten ist zumindest
die sitze umgeklappt das heißt entweder
sie hat beim autofahren zell viel
gemacht oder ja ich weiss ich 18 60 16
okay das ist hier auf jeden fall nicht
selbst gefahren sowie übrigens dass ich
gerade hier so komplett verpacke aber
das ist halt wirklich hart schwierig das
bild ist mein lieblingsbild von denen
nicht ausgesucht habe wo soll ich jetzt
in runde jahren sagen oder den menschen
ja ich würde sagen 688 das traurige ist
dass beim und näher dran war als bei den
meisten menschen bis er jetzt immer
wieder ein menschenbild wie hat glaube
ich nicht
in den schulranzen auf dem rücken das so
mit das schwierigste bisher finde ich
würde sagen 17 16 18 sagst du schaffst
das nämlich war bei dem bild wenn ich
persönlich ein bisschen schwierig
die sache ist dass mädels ja eh schon
immer so vom kompletten aussehende
früher weiter sind als jungs von daher
würde ich sagen dass sie 15 ist echt ich
hätte gedacht ist wird sie viel älter
hier mal wieder ein junge für dich
er hat bartwuchs dass das muss man schon
mal sagen und auch so vom kompletten
klamotten stil würde ich sagen dass er
tatsächlich 19 ist er 16 16 person barth
lässt einen direkt älter aussehen weil
das so krass apropos bat das nächste
wird es auch wieder mit bart ist ein
boshaftes bild in so einem goldenen
sessel wie bereits gesagt er hat barth
und allgemein so vom kompletten
klamotten stil ist es auch er was was
man glaube ich früher getragen hat von
daher würde ich sagen dass er schon ein
bisschen älter ist und zwar 21 27 27
okay das hätte ich nie gedacht wenn
jemand wieder ein mädchen nach den
beiden jungs ist auch wieder so schwer
also das jetzt so plötzlich so ein 12 13
jahre kandidat ist glaube ich jetzt eher
weniger es ist ein schönes foto im wald
was mich auch und 0,0 weiterbringt
allerdings würde ich sie auf 16 schätzen
sie sagten das doch nicht wahr ich bin
so schlecht in dieser kacke auch wieder
ein schönes foto am meer das ist
ich würde sagen dass sie 18 ist 2020
wird nichts zu retten
das bild ist schwarz weiß und ich glaube
das macht nichts ich glaube dass das ja
allgemein sondern etwas nach was heißt
alternative raster ist aber halt mit
ponys und schwarz weiß und mit diesen in
diesem stau perfekt drauf und so das
soll ja auch so ein bisschen so
erwachsen und cool foto mäßig wirken und
daher würde ich sie allein so vom
ästhetischen aspekt her auf 19 schätzen
was das kann doch nicht wahr sein wieder
ein foto mit filter
das ist ganz schwer
der filter verändert hat haut und augen
und alles mögliche so krass also ich
würde sie trotz des filters der sie ja
schon länger macht trotzdem noch relativ
jung schätzen
und zwar auf 14 12 12 ich wollte erst
zwölf sah dachte ich nur das zu jungen
nächste kandidat ist die dann junge was
geht er oben auf jeden fall poster von
call of duty hängen das heißt eigentlich
müsste er über 18 sein ist aber glaube
ich nicht hat die seiten auf fast null
millimeter und das bringt mich auch
überhaupt nicht weiter allerdings würde
ich ihn auf 14 schätzen er ist auch 12
12 wert der bilder von ballerspielen 18
hängen das ist glaube ich auch relativ
schwierig für dich alter das ist so
schwer also dass das kann alles sein von
14 bis 27 finde ich das kann man ganz
ganz ganz ganz schwer einschätzen bei
solchen bildern aber um jetzt eine zahl
zu sagen würde ich trotzdem eher sagen
jünger und zwar 16
richtig ehrlich immer bei den bildern
weltwirtschaft alter ok krass das war
komisch schnell so die ganzen einfachen
so glaube ich die kritiker nicht aber
die wo man denke das könnte alles sein
derartig und dann ist es richtig das ist
die nächste kandidatin ist auch wieder
sauschwer 14 16 war immer immer ist es
immer so in den berg würde ich wieder
denken so schwer war wahrscheinlich erst
uns jetzt wieder spielt sagen sie es ein
bisschen älter
das sieht so aus als hätte sie gerade
angel ich würde sagen 19.15 wieder ein
junge der coop ziemlich lustig also mein
lieber kollege ich würde sagen dass er
auf jeden fall noch ein bisschen jünger
ist ein man sieht ja auch hier das noch
sein kinderzimmer
von daher würde ich sagen dass er 13 ist
12 12 ich glaube ich habe ja schon mal
so ein bioladen aber ich glaube jetzt
heute bin ich so unfassbar schlecht
kommt aber auch zum letzten foto
vielleicht schaffst du das ja wenigstens
es ist so schwer was guckst du mich so
an hättest du wirst ja ist weil es so
schwer ist bei jedem das stellt so eine
herausforderung für mich da bei ihr
würde ich allerdings sagen dass die 14
ist richtig richtig weiter also man kann
auf jeden fall schon abschließend hier
am ende des videos festhalten dass ich
überhaupt nicht euer alter einschätzen
kann
[Musik]